le temps a fait son ouvrage mais
l'œeuvre a résisté aux outrages elle
garde tout son mystère l'antiire marque
maison a acheté à un confrère cette
pièce d'exception sans en connaître
l'histoire une seule certitude c'est un
meuble signé de l'ébéniste jean-pa
mazaro la qualité est présente et
surtout il y a l'estamp que je va vous
montrer qui
confirme que c'est bien lui leur un
réputé chez les aristocrates grand
bourgeois du Second Empire le jeune
ébéniste de lonelonniier quitte sa
province dans les années 1850 pour
conquérir le faubourg Saint-Antoine le
succès est
rapide voyez qu'il y a des courbures et
ces courbures elles sont reprises par
les portes c'està dire que ce ne sont
pas des portes qui sont droites elles
suivent
vraiment voilà il y a plein de petits
détails qui font que je vais pas dire
que c'est un petit cheedœvre mais que
c'est une très très belle exécution
c'est toujours des pièces d'exception
donc si vous voulez un ordre de prix
pour ça il faut compter pour cet
ensemble là aux alentours de 50000 €
voilà ce qui n'est pas du tout le prix
que coûterait même à faire refaire ce
mobilier là aujourd'hui si encore nous
en étions
capable qui achète encore aujourd'hui
les meubles de mazaro des Chinois
sensible à la beauté du geste et jusqu'à
l'embargo des Russes nostalgiques
c'est à Paris que les amoureux du style
néogothique ou néoenaissance peuvent
admirer le travail de mazaro sans
débourser un centime en 1871 l'Hôtel de
Ville est détruit pour le reconstruire
on fait appel à plusieurs artistes dont
Jean-Paul mazaro pour la grande salle à
manger et la porte
d'honneur 20 ans plus tard le vent
tourne pour les bénistes la crise
économique le contraint à la faillite
maisine depuis ses plus jeunes années sa
collection d'œuvres d'art est vendu aux
enchères mazaro avait acheté près de 600
[Musique]
tableaux jusqu'au bout il a il n'a songé
qu'à une chose c'est effectivement
éponger ses dettes
euh il n'a pas laissé de créancier
impayé là aussi sur le plan de de la
pensée de la moralité ça dit beaucoup du
du du personnage oui il a gagné
énormément d'argent sur la très longue
durée il a beaucoup construit il a
beaucoup vendu il s'est enriché il en a
fait profiter énormément de monde il ne
faut pas l'oublier euh c'est un Mesen
hein et lorsqu'il décède ben oui
effectivement il est sans doute ruiné
mais ces créanciers ont tous été
réglés le Jurassien n'a jamais oublié
d'où il venait il faisait des
allers-retours entre son pays natal et
la capitale à partir de 1866 il AG
grandi sa propriété de montchauvier près
de lonelonniier il achète beaucoup de
terre et devient même
viticulteur de son vivant et avant de
tout perdre il a donné une centaine
d'œuvres d'art au musée de Lon le Sonier
une histoire que l'on apprend lors de la
visite dédiée au messen du
musée c'est notre identité
puisqueaujourd'hui encore nos dernières
acquisitions de beauart se font sur
cette base qui a permis de constituer
Jean-Paul mazaro ces œuvres aujourd'hui
elles sont encore exposées c'est-à-dire
que le choix qu'il a fait il y a plus
d'une centaine d'années ce sont encore
nos valeurs ici aujourd'hui que je vous
laisserai apprécier mazaro a donné au
musée quatre tableaux de Gustave Courbet
comme pour la centaine d'autres œuvres
d'art le messeng jaien a demandé que ses
dons soit à jamais la possession du
musée de
lonelonniier